Charles Krauthammer has been a legendary
conservative voice for years he has
appeared on special report providing his
signature analysis on the all-star panel
I found him hinged often don't hear
hinge but it was stream-of-consciousness
I mean it was a performance unlike any
other the hope was Charles would return
to the panel and Fox News after
treatment for cancer today that hope was
dashed when he announced the cancer had
returned and that it was aggressive and
spreading rapidly adding my doctors tell
me their best estimate is that I have
only a few weeks left to live this is
the final verdict my fight is over yet
Charles isn't feeling sorry for himself
noting he has lived life to the fullest
I leave this life with no regrets it was
a wonderful life full and complete with
the great loves and great endeavors that
make it worth living I am sad to leave
but I leave with the knowledge that I
lived the life that I intended Fox News
executive chairman Rupert Murdoch spoke
for us all saying Charles has been a
profound source of personal and
intellectual inspiration for all of us
at Fox News his always principled stand
on the most important issues of our time
has been a guiding star in an often
turbulent world a world that has too
many superficial thinkers vulnerable to
the ebb and flow of fashion and a world
that unfortunately has only one Charles
Krauthammer his words his ideas his
dignity and his integrity will resonate
within our society and within me for
many many years to come even those who
disagree with Charles respect his
intellect read Charles Krauthammer Scott
column in the post say he's a brilliant
man well you know when you get praise
from President Clinton and you're from
my side of the of the aisle that means
that my career's done I mean I'm toast
more recently Charles had a little fun
with his clashes with President Trump I
thought I was going to be the surprise
new national security adviser so I was
someone I think it's still also pointed
well I've gotta wait because you know I
don't I miss you Brett
the truth is Charles has made his mark
on all of us and we'll all miss him
in Washington Mike Emanuel Fox News